What is it
some sort of energy field be careful rambeau
captain rambeau watch it!
Tomorrow nothing can prepare you
Wanda, can you read me? Who's doing this to you?
for what's next
Okay marvel good disney plus first series
Wandavision excellent paul and lizzie my friends
you are so good in this it's a hard enough to
bring off that concept let alone to riddle it with
all the excitement that all us fans are waiting
for to see what happened to wanda next and why
on earth were watching sitcoms to find out over
the generations they appeared on the television
in america but you do all of it in one fell swoop
and it is addictive television i've only seen five
i've got to rush this message and let's see the
rest of them fans don't start watching tonight
unless you want to have a sleepless night
if that's possible i don't know i don't!
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
Wandavision video marvel just dropped a bunch of
new footage paul bettany also just dropped a clip
talking about a really big avengers crossover that
i think is dr strange so i'll explain what's going
on with that too because we know that we're going
to cross over with doctor strange too so there's
a lot of people expecting a benedict cumberbatch
cameo scene during the series i'm doing videos
for all the episodes so be sure to subscribe to
get everything we're doing a disney plus giveaway
for memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and post all your theories about
what's going on inside wandavision careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened so far
i'll talk about the footage in just a second
this is that clip of paul bettany where i believe
that he's talking about benedict cumberbatch
coming on the show as doctor strange i think
they're going to be massively surprised by
the end of the show oh my god they're going to
look at the mcu in a whole new light and also
have a much deeper understanding about in what
direction it's moving um i would also say that
you know so many things get leaked and and people
find out about certain things but there's this
thing that's been kept completely under wraps
that is that happens and i work with this actor
that i have fireworks together and uh the scenes
are great and uh i think people be really excited
uh i've always wanted to work with this guy and uh
it's pretty the scenes are pretty intense there's
some gossip that i'm probably i probably shouldn't
have told you and i'm going to probably get a call
from marvel security saying why the hell did you
say that uh but i did and um and there it is so
during that he's just talking about an actor that
he's always wanted to work with you keep in mind
that vision has never had scenes with benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange character that was
his big thing during this clip working with an
actor that he's never had the chance to work
with before even though technically they're both
marvel actors they were both in avengers infinity
war vision and doctor strange never were together
during that movie so technically they never did
work together and what he's talking about is
this big avengers level movie event that's going
to be happening towards the end of the series i'll
address that too but i also believe that the agnes
character is another big doctor strange connection
to those movies and what's happening during doctor
strange too because of some of the footage that we
see during this trailer so during these new scenes
from episode 4 and beyond some of this footage
is from later episodes too but during the scenes
monica rambo before the events of episode 2 in her
normal sword gear approaches the barrier to west
view scarlet witch's alternate reality before they
really know what it is or how it will affect them
she touches it it crackles like the static shock
effect that you used to get from crt tvs jimmy wu
yells at her to be careful because it looks like
she's about to accidentally fall into a tv show
literally and metaphorically because of the way
things work inside this mcu house of m reality
jimmy wu also calls her captain rambo meaning that
she's probably come up through the military like
the air force before joining sword just like her
mother was in the air force with captain marvel
there was the other trailer footage where it seems
like she's the one wearing that red helmet and it
kind of seems like her mother's helmet a little
bit you remember that her mother was an air force
pilot her call sign was photon which was a big
easter egg for her daughter monica rambo's comic
book name or one of her comic book names after she
was a version of captain marvel when she debuted
for the first time monica rambo was called captain
marvel it's just that her costume look like this
and actually when they first announced tayonna
paris she's the actress playing monica rambo
and she came on stage during comic con the outfit
that she was wearing had these giant sleeves which
was meant to be a bit of a reference to her comic
book captain marvel costume with the giant sleeves
but notice the town of west view from outside
the barrier looks like a totally normal town
like it normally would on any given day it's
only once you travel inside that everything
turns into the sitcom decades of tv like you see
scarlet witch driving into town in that car and
everything turns on like a tv set is turning on
as if that's her activating this sort of bubble
of reality this simulation like a matrix however
you want to think about it and if it wasn't clear
they also reveal in the other footage here
that this is all happening in a new jersey
town that's where westview is because we're
meant to be relatively close to new york city
upstate new york where the old avengers base was
so it seems like scarlet witch just came here to
this normal town of westview like oh i'm going to
go try and live out this life with vision whatever
plan that she developed with whatever help she had
doing it and she just arbitrarily picked this town
that seemed like a totally normal quiet place like
okay nobody will mind if i do this here but before
she showed up this was just a totally normal town
and these were all the normal towns people with
the exception of agnes i'll explain that in
a second too there's some clues in that big
board of ids that you see during the trailer right
now it just seems like vision is the only one
inside this town that has no idea what's going on
and every time he does get a little idea scarlet
witch blips him back so to speak to make another
avengers reference and in this other footage you
see darcy from the thor movies the other sword
agents that have files on all the different
talents people the funny thing here though is
that agnes is the only one with no photo id
i know you don't see dottie on the board here or
some of the other towns people that's probably
just because this frame the way they frame the
shot here cuts off a lot of the other board so
the other people of the town are probably just off
the edges of the frame here then you see jimmy woo
on the other end of that scene from episode 2
trying to contact scarlet witch wanda wanda can
you read me who's doing this to you i think this
is just meant to give you a sense for the timeline
of the show like this is playing out over a very
small number of days very quickly they confirm
my theory that it's darcy who was watching the
nick at night style video feed from inside the
town on the tvs she was the person from the end of
episode 1 at the bank of monitors and tv equipment
you also notice that the tv that she's watching
here in this scene when it's the events of episode
3 her little tv set has changed to a 1970s looking
tv set is different from the tv set during episode
one she's watching this from outside the barrier
inside these sword-based tents so this might have
something to do with its connection like the way
that they're actually feeding the video to the tv
from inside the barrier it's also more evidence
that the fake things that scarlet witch creates
or changes inside the barrier can survive in
the normal mcu dimension that's just all in
service of her children billy and tommy wicken and
speed surviving after the events of Wandavision
the thing about agnes here though on this board
here the fact that she doesn't have any photo id
they don't know who she is and she doesn't have
a last name either unlike the other townspeople
it's all probably because as agatha harkness
we believe she's really ag of the harkness
agnes is just a fake name that she's using
she's a magic user just like doctor strange
so now we're talking about more doctor strange two
connections she would be powerful enough at least
to defend herself or protect herself a little bit
against the effects of what scarlet witch is doing
warping reality like this and you keep in mind
that it seems like agnes or agatha harkness
has been manipulating scarlet witch since
the very beginning of episode 1. way before
we see monica rambo and jimmy wu step up and
her sneak in during the events of episode 2.
even during agnes's first scene in episode 1
some of the dialogue she has and the references
she makes makes it seem like she knows all about
scarlet witch's powers and the secrets of what's
really going on so early theory she probably
had something to do with manipulating scarlet
witch before the events of episode 1 and maybe
even gave her the idea or helped her create this
alternate reality so she had to have gotten some
help from someone or something talking about more
big cosmic easter eggs everyone's still hoping for
mephisto references it could be nightmare it could
be mephisto it just seems like there is something
more cosmic at play here something more connected
to the doctor strange mythology i know there
was the marquee easter egg where it says big red
and kidnapped on it in the background in town
people wondered if that was a mephisto reference
big red i believe is a reference to scarlet witch
herself but it is more of the townspeople sort of
trying to let other people outside the reality
like the sword agents know that they're trapped
in here like we've been kidnapped by big red
by scarlet witch i just did a big video about
sword during marvel phase four and what's going
on with them during the events of Wandavision
where they've been this whole time why nick fury
waited this long to roll them out so i'll link
that below in the video description there'll be
bigger sword stuff happening all across marvel
phase four they're like the new version of shield
and remember how shield popped up a lot during
marvel phase one phase two until captain america
winter soldier and they sort of blew it up from
the inside and earlier paul bettany was talking
about how the series would go from the sitcom
decades up to a big avengers level movie by the
final episodes that's probably what he's talking
about when he talks about big battle scenes and
the big actor he's always wanted to have scenes
with and them having big action scenes together
that we believe now is probably doctor strange
benedict cumberbatch he also did a live stream
with the cast it was a little bit funny he was
just being silly with them but because elizabeth
olsen is going to be in doctor strange 2 next
he was helping them hype up the launch of
Wandavision so no surprise that they would
also try and then bring him in for the last couple
of episodes early theory too another big doctor
strange too crossover connection scarlet witch's
children survive the events of the finale what
happens to them immediately after Wandavision well
they would probably go to some place like kamar
taj where they could help be raised and learn
about their powers without hurting anyone else
it would also explain when the events of
doctor strange ii multiverse of madness pick up
why scarlet witch is in such close proximity to
doctor strange because she's literally in a safe
place where he put her raising her children but
everyone posts all your theories about doctor
strange crossing over with Wandavision in benedict
cumberbatch my full episode 4 video is going to
post friday just like normal so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss it
congratulations navi you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Wandavision video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can
get your contact details everyone click here
for all my Wandavision episode videos and click
here for that brand new godzilla vs kong trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!